good morning you have a car Michael good
morning I'm naked you're not naked what
the heck hold on hold on good morning
let's
go so today we're going to be at keten
keten keten yeah keten this is our last
pork stop and tomorrow is going to be a
see but you know what today we're going
to go eat some crab we're going to go on
a famous crab Expedition and then eat it
I don't know if we're going to eat it
but we're going to go but we should eat
some we're going to catch them and then
we're going to see lots of wildlife it's
the highly recommended tour to do so I'm
ready how about
[Music]
you first up we're going to have some
Alaska cof
coffee they're famous for their white
mocha here and they're also famous for
their rainy clouds so we're lucky
another lucky day sunny days
yeah oh yeah it's very sweet I don't
think going like it but I like
[Music]
it Evan's loving this St I love amethyst
yeah cuz they have a lot of
[Music]
MTH Evan what are you most looking
forward to spending time with Nina oh I
I meant this trip uh this today spending
time with
Nina that's nice okay and then what else
that's all the MS okay
[Music]
good how was your lunch Evan filling
filling yeah well also cuz you had a
breakfast yeah yeah yeah we didn't
really get to see the city but maybe
after cuz we got a boat the
[Music]
catch
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of scary is holding the crap yeah
Evan you're fighting with the crap I'm
not fighting no no we're just chilling
we're
chilling it's huge eh yeah it's kind of
[Music]
scary how was the the tour Evan I liked
it yeah he was so into the eag go he's
like oh there's Eagle oh there's eag
look at over there I was like what's
there I don't even know but he spotted a
lot of eagles I was I was the eagle
spider for the boat that's it was good
yeah okay so we have to get back to the
boat in 20 minutes but we'll rush to
this famous creep Street has like some
shops and then and other Bunch stores
Evan want to get this crate before we
get onto the boat so I hope it's
good we're not getting CR we're just
seeing this little Bunch stores that
is awesome little tin awesome little
tiny store you can't miss you have to
get it you have to go away so we're just
going to we're just going to walk around
it to pretend like oh my God this that
St oh my God it's so crazy yeah but I
don't see any store just the
backyard oh okay
[Music]
it's nice
here store on the
water and I spot my little eyes
someone's wearing the Bel
sweater I don't even see
[Music]
Bel it's dinner time M you were looking
forward to this restaurant actually cuz
we came upstairs last time get the
cooked your own meat
[Music]
yeah EV try your
salad oh that looks good that cheese
looks good with the bizam
vinegar yeah it's good
yummy doesn't B taste to it I'm not a
fan of but oh I have to we this apron
why you're going to be messy H dum
[Music]
Okay evan try your steak new your strip
line did you cook it
yourself so Evan Hardy Coke when he
cooks it means very special he's cooking
for himself right now fet M well you had
some of mine too so I cooked for you
okay Nina's gonna try her f
m there it is cooked to Perfection with
some mushroom
sauce
and thumbs up mhm let's go let's
[Music]
go Evan Yo how was your dinner oh wow uh
really good yeah it was great you cook
your own meal c a meal we had blankets
cuz it was cold upstairs we uh yeah it
was nice I liked it it was a good last
uh was our last day in a port yeah yeah
and you saw you you saw very red Sun
yeah we didn't what did we get a video
of it no the sun was setting and it was
uh red full red sun which is crazy it
was really beautiful hello Evan hello
how you how you doing
did you sleep okay no no oh what
happened did you sleep okay no the bed
is too small well that's what happened
to me it feels like the bed it's
actually King it's it it's it's two
single bed but I feel like smaller than
two single
bed yeah we're both giant people so you
know yeah you know what yeah it's so
true okay yeah today is day at C we're
going to be doing some um uh Pine all
pine uh cruising cruising as much as the
day at see we're going go we're going
somewhere on the Inside passage to see
some SES from the boat we're not getting
off so we'll take some uh videos for you
guys to see what that all looks like we
have a couple hours before we get there
so we're going to get we're going to get
some work done I have a list of things
that I'm going to talk with my beautiful
wife with who's our chief heart officer
our chief operating officer really Chief
everything officer except Evan who's me
and then Nina does everything so uh we
have to we have some meetings to
important things to discuss you's having
her tea yeah and we're going to take you
on the journey let's
go so how was the session Evan pretty
good we got we got sidetracked by a lot
of different fires that started burning
but uh we got it done we always do great
things come to us uh we probably have uh
what this is my list of things that we
needed to do and
yeah we got we didn't finish the stuff
yeah we we got nothing fully done but
it's okay we're going to go eat lunch
and then with our full bellies attack
the day
[Music]
yeah lunch was fun Evan just loved
chatting with got so chatty with these
Australians whatever it's Evan was Evan
was the while was chatting Nina was such
a chatter box she loves Australians yeah
but nice people they're nice
yeah yeah Australians are I don't think
I've met a non- nice
Australian okay not yet not yet but yeah
they're nice
fry
hello what did you do I filmed videos oh
went on the balcony film some videos
okay because uh the content train must
continue so yeah I had a good time on
the balcony yeah good hopefully the
sound was okay yeah it was quite loud
but I think we can use some AI to uh
take out some of the noise yeah and Nina
was hard at work very very hard napping
relaxing yeah candy crushing I didn't
play Candy Crush okay yeah now we're
going to go see if there's any extra
snacks cuz just packed up cuz we leave
tomorrow
yeah
[Music]
what's your favorite plant I love Orchid
they're so
pretty they only bloom twice a year and
it take them so long to bloom and once
they bloom the flower will last for like
almost
[Music]
month
Evan this is your last dinner before we
head
to vancou yeah you excited you excited
yeah I'm excited with you're excited you
tell me uh yeah yeah no it was good uh
we packed up yeah I saw a whale from the
from the uh balcony that was cool mhm
and now it's dinner
time
[Music]
[Applause]
how you feeling Evan ready to go ready
to go you SL well last night did I no I
did not sleep well last night we got 2
hours sleep oh wow it's okay ready to go
we're in
Vancouver I got some scenes while Nina
was relaxing of the boat pulling into
the Vancouver Harbor and we're in Canada
so we go through customs hopefully it's
fast we hop on our flight to get home
and see
the doggies that's right
[Music]
hello Evan hello you're ready to go I'm
ready I'm caring both both our suitcases
can vog
[Music]
yeah you don't look so good Evan no yeah
you were so tired you closed your eyes a
little bit up and down waves waves
but we're going home good I could get my
home bed more than two hours sleep
[Music]
tonight are you doing okay yeah it's
actually faster
coming cuz we we party a little bit late
actually yeah I guess going west is
slower than going east but that's great
home early dog's going to freak out yeah
let's get our ride and go home yeah
yeah ready hello hello can you open the
door here we hello here we go let's go
hello my
goodness
a
[Music]
if you want to go back and see how this
crazy Alaska trip all started check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there all righty this is
the moment Evan this is the moment we're
going away we're going away where are we
going we're going to Alaska for how long
for I don't know how long 2 weeks 10
days 12 days 14 days I think so